Je ne vous apprends rien si je vous dis que les intelligences artificielles sont de plus en plus douées dans des tas de domaines
que ce soit dans la médecine avec Watson d'IBM qui est capable d'ingurgiter
40 millions de documents en 15 secondes par la finance avec Ether qui a permis d'économiser
151 millions de dollars de pertes en trois semaines ou encore avec les voitures autonomes de Tesla qui permettent aux utilisateurs
de s'endormir au volant
l'intelligence artificielle
nous montre qu'elle sait aujourd'hui faire aussi bien
voire mieux que nous dans de nombreux domaines et on pourrait croire que les domaines artistiques ne sont pas touchés parce qu'ils font appel à
la sensibilité et de la créativité mais pourtant il n'en est rien
La musique que vous écoutez à l'instant est fait par une intelligence artificielle
et s'appelle AIVA et c'est la première intelligence artificielle à recevoir des droits SACEM
ce court métrage et la mise en image d'un script écrit par une intelligence artificielle
et ses costumes vous l'avez deviné ont été réalisés par intelligence artificielle également
alors on pourrait penser que faire un opéra c'est pas très différent de tout ça et pourtant aucune intelligence artificielle ne peut le réaliser
et il faut que je vous explique pourquoi
L'opéra est un art ancien mais c'est surtout un art complexe voire même total car c'est un art au carrefour de nombreux autres
déjà il est à la rencontre de deux arts qui sautent aux yeux et aux oreilles
ce sont la dramaturgie et la musique.
Un opéra c'est une histoire avec une narration des personnages et le tout et mis en musique avec un orchestre
et des chanteurs et chanteuses d'opéra qui sont assez souvent
exceptionnels mais ce n'est pas que ça. C'est aussi une mise en scène qui sublime le texte et la performance des artistes
et enfin c'est aussi des costumes des décors et tout un travail de minutie autour de ces éléments qui vont plonger l'audience dans une esthétique
mais bon on l'avait dit en intro tout ça n'empêche pas une intelligence artificielle d'en faire un
on pourrait imaginer qu'un jour un opéra aussi puisse être crée par une intelligence artificielle
une intelligence artificielle qui saurait appuyer sur les bons boutons de notre cerveau pour nous faire ressentir
exactement ce qu'elle veut et nous transporter plus loin que ce que pourrait faire Carmen ou la Traviata.
Alors qu'est ce qui coince ? Pour répondre à cette question il faut déjà comprendre ce qu'est une intelligence artificielle.
C'est un mot un peu fourre tout et souvent mal utilisé
mais globalement c'est un ou une série d'algorithmes et souvent c'est même plus précisément un réseau de neurones.
Sans rentrer dans le détail c'est un réseau auquel on donne un ensemble de données qui les analyse et qui à partir de ces données
réalise sa version à lui c'est comme ça que fonctionnent les intelligences artificielles
dont j'ai parlé en intro c'est aussi ce qu'on appelle du machine learning
et c'est comme ça qu'elles sont plus fortes que nous parce que forcément
nous on ne peut pas analyser 15000 script pour pouvoir en créer un. Ces intelligences artificielles là elle partage une particularité
elles sont ce qu'on appelle en anglais narrow artificial intelligence
en gros elles sont très fortes pour faire des tâches spécifiques
mais elle ne savent faire que ça. Ça rassemble à peu près toutes les intelligences artificielles que vous avez croisé dans votre vie.
Elles ont une intelligence que je dirais verticale dans le sens où elles peuvent creuser qu'un aspect des choses.
En français on appelle ça les intelligences artificielles
faible. Je vous avoue que je suis pas fan du terme. L'autre type d'I.A.c'est l'I.A.qu'on va appeler general artificial intelligence.
C'est une I.A. qui est capable de faire des liens entre des choses qui sont très différentes.
C'est le genre d'I.A. que l'on voit dans des films de science fiction
et qui serait doté de conscience et d'émotion. En gros c'est une I.A. qui a une intelligence très proche de la nôtre.
Cette fois je dirais qu'elles ont une intelligence horizontal dans le sens où elles peuvent lier différentes verticale en français on parle d'intelligence artificielle
forte
et en fait c'est ce genre d'I.A. qu'il faut pour créer un opéra.
Parce que comme je vous le disais un opéra c'est plusieurs arts à la fois mais surtout c'est plusieurs arts à la fois qui fonctionnent
ensemble et qui se répondent. Chacun est au service de l'autre c'est ce qui donne à l'opéra son unité donc avoir plusieurs
artificials narrow intelligence ça ne marchera pas vous aurez de la musique avec un script peut-être une mise en scène et des costumes
mais rien n'aura de sens rien ira ensemble car l'I.A. doit comprendre que la mise en scène doit servir la narration
que les costumes doivent servir le propos et que la musique doit refléter l'émotion. Pour ça il faut une general artificial intelligence
et on en est loin, très loin. Oren Etzioni le directeur de l'Allen institute d'intelligence artificielle à Seattle a déclaré
"Nous n'avons pas d'ordinateur qui puisse fonctionner avec les capacités d'un enfant de 6 ans
ou même d'un enfant de 3 ans
et donc on est très loin d'une intelligence artificielle forte."
Les technologies ont toujours eu une place importante dans l'opéra. A l'Opéra Bastille par exemple il ya des chariots porte décor qui font 400 mètres
carrés qui pèsent 54 tonnes et qui permettent de transporter des décors de 80 tonnes
cela a été fabriquée spécialement
pour l'Opéra Bastille et cela permet à un technicien de changer tout seul des décors de 80 tonnes en trois quatre minutes
le Palais Garnier aussi est plein de prouesses techniques majeures qui étaient révolutionnaires pour l'époque
et on peut donc s'attendre à ce que l'Opéra embrasse ces nouvelles technologies et cela commence déjà
L'année dernière au Palais Garnier on pouvait assister aux représentations de Only the Sound Remains, un opéra où certaines voix avaient été traités par ordinateur
Dans un futur très proche des humains pourraient être assistée d'I.A. pour écrire composer, habiller et mettre en scène des opéras
un travail d'équipe entre nous et eux.
Si le sujet vous intéresse j'ai fait une autre vidéo sur la chaîne youtube de l'Opéra de Paris
c'est une vie dans un petit peu plus sociologique qui se demande pourquoi y'a que les vieux qui vont à l'opéra
voilà en tout cas cette vidéo
elle a été faite évidemment partenariat avec l'Opéra de Paris. Merci beaucoup
de m'avoir permis de la faire et de m'avoir donné accès à tout ça
J'espère qu'elle vous aura plu moi en tout cas ça m'a vachement plus de la faire
et on se revoit la semaine prochaine pour une autre vidéo ! Ciao !